on Wednesday Rasmussen Reports released
its daily presidential tracking poll
they put President Trump at 48 percent
approval that's a four point jump in two
days from when asked mucin a five point
increase from his recent low of 43
percent on May 16th now it is worth
noting that other polls are far less
favorable to Trump to contemporaneous
polls the Economist and Gallup have made
40% and 38 percent respectively and Fox
News has been 38 percent - but if the
Trump bump is real it makes a bit of
sense that's for three reasons number
one Trump isn't tweeting I know a lot of
Zach likes like when T tweets but
because Trump is overseas and visibly
traveling the globe he's not up at all
hours watching MSNBC and CNN and
tweeting nasty notes to the hosts or
retweeting botched submarines of Fox and
Friends Chiron he's also not pouring
more gasoline on the Trump Russia
kindling the media have set he hasn't
tweeted about FBI director James Comey
or reports that he told intelligence
officials he'd appreciate it if they'd
exonerate him or any of the other
anonymous material coming out of the
media daily that means that these
stories tend to that quickly since
anonymous stories aren't being confirmed
by Trump's own hand and since Trump
isn't insisting that his communications
team rushed to the nearest microphones
apparent his talking points most of the
damage on the Trump Russia stuff has
been self-inflicted and it's easy to see
when Trump stops in putting said damage
on himself
second the country isn't collapsing
Trump left the country the country's
fine the less promulgates this myth
whereby the president must sit at the
controls of the airliner that is the
United States each and every day lest we
all go full zombie apocalypse on one
another and the plane crashes into a
building instead Trump is out of the
country partying it up with glowing orbs
and swords and the country is getting
along pretty much just fine nobody's
dying
nobody's panicking in other words a
predictable government is the best
available option and Trump gallivanting
around reminds us all he's not capable
of screwing it up this badly
terrorism is a winning issue for Trump
this is the third point the terror
attack on Monday obviously helped Trump
politically because the left is so damn
irresponsible about it
Trump's perspective you were on vetted
Muslims in the West means fewer unwanted
Muslims telling each other people in
killing other people in the West then
that's eminently correct his skepticism
of the radical Islam resonates far
better than the left asinine John Lennon
imagine ask pseudo philosophy Trump was
elected to bomb the bleep out of Isis
seeing this water of eight-year-old
girls and a pop concert reminds people
that's a task worth pursuing President
Trump should be making notes when it
comes back to the US he should be the
same president
Trump we're seeing abroad muted but
strong of ambassador Minh when the time
is right if he does all that maybe we
can get this thing back on the rails I'm
Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
so we have a huge show coming up for you
today coming up in just a couple of
minutes we're supposed to have senator
Ben Sasse from Nebraska whose book the
vanishing American adult our
coming-of-age crisis and how to rebuild
a culture of self-reliance is is now
number three on the New York Times best
seller chart I'm a big fan of Senator
Sasa's obviously one of the last honest
conservatives in Washington DC hopefully
we get the technology worked out he's
supposed to call in so we'll chat with
him about the issues of the day we're
also going to talk about what's
happening in Montana where a Republican
candidate for a special election
congressional seat literally
body-slammed reporter and we'll talk
about why it is that we continue to vote
for people who bodyslam supports and why
it is that that's actually somewhat
understandable we'll get to all of that
plus the mailbag but first I want to say
thank you to our sponsors over at wink
so if you are someone who doesn't know
much about one like me if you think that
a wine bottle vinegar are just separated
by the taste essentially then wink is
for you because you don't need to have
expertise with wine
they provide the expertise for you you
go to try wink calm its winc try winked
calm and you fill out like a quick
survey that asks you what tastes you
like together what kind of meal you're
going to be eating that night and then
you can order a bottle of wine direct
from link and try wyndcomm /bin you get
$20 off plus complimentary shipping and
the fact of the matter is that the
average bottle of wine at wint costs
like 13 bucks so 20 bucks off plus
complements or shipping means that
you're going to be getting someone for
yourself try wink calm slash pen and the
wine that you get is going to be better
quality because number one they cut out
the middleman that's why it's so cheap
and number two it's also that they're
going to help you pick the wine that
best conforms to your palate and best
conforms to the meal it's great if
you're going over to someone's house and
you want to look sophisticated like you
actually know what wine is good and what
wanted to bring as opposed to just
grabbing a bottle of wine off the shelf
of your local liquor mer tri wink calm
is the best way to do it so try winked
calm winc calm slash Ben you get $20 off
your first order now plus complimentary
shipping and the try wink on slash menus
that slash Ben also so that they know
that we sent you so let's jump right in
with senator Ben Sasse senator sass
thanks so much for joining the show
really appreciate your time thank you
for having me on I'm grateful for the
invite okay so senator stance I do want
to ask you about you
but first i would be remissed I didn't
ask you about the news of the day I just
want to get your basic take on how we
should be looking at the situation in
which a congressional candidate in
Montana has apparently body-slammed
a reporter it's been confirmed basically
by Fox News report you know what should
I think obviously everybody of goodwill
can look at this and say this is
ridiculous but how should Republicans be
treating this because now they're stuck
between a rock and a hard place in the
middle of an election they don't want to
see a Democrat when a seat how do you
think Republicans ought to be treating
this yeah so I've been in commitments
all morning back-to-back so I know
almost nothing current on it except for
just that the top-line fact of what
happened last night and it seems to me
pretty obvious that if you are seeking a
job as a public servant what are your
most fundamental duties is to teach
American civics and since the First
Amendment is the beating heart of the
American experiment and of American
civics that means many many many things
but one of the most basic things the
First Amendment means is you don't body
slam a reporter you celebrate the First
Amendment well I appreciate your candor
on that senator staff I think one of the
big problems is obviously that if
leadership in both party doesn't say the
same thing that you do then what you end
up with this sort of prisoner's dilemma
and explain that a little bit to the
listeners you don't put the sort of
prisoner's dilemma where people feel
okay I have to pick the the second worst
choice and obviously we're electing a
congressman we're not electing a pastor
and that means that even if somebody
does something that I find abhorrent
he's going to be a better legislator
than somebody else but it the leadership
of both parties needs to stand together
and say that when it's a problem cuz
they won't do it that when people act
like this that they should not be seated
in my opinion I don't know you think
about that yeah so I'm shooting straight
with you that I've had zero
conversations with anybody about where
any of the leaders are on an issue like
that or whether or not there's been a
call for that joint press conference but
let's just distinguish between short
term and long term if here's what I
really care about I get that in a short
term basis all through life people are
often presented with choices that feel
like a lesser of two evils discussion
that's not where I spend any of my
energy I spend all of my time and energy
on this which is what are we doing now
to build a country
where the American people will
understand our shared narrative as a
people and where there will be more
public trust five and ten and fifteen
and twenty years from now because we are
not one election away from the eschaton
we're not one election away from
electing the guy who will drive some
majority that's going to pass all their
great legislation and they're going to
bring about utopia America is centered
in the local communities where people
work and worship and where they're
designing the next great app and what
they're persuading people to join the
Rotary Club and politics is to provide a
framework for that and right now our
politics is so lame and boring and
stupidly short-sighted then it always
feels like people think they're trying
to make the lesser of two evils choice
that will bring about heaven on earth
it's not coming via the city I'm talking
to you from DZ and this city is filled
with people who are just not interesting
enough to project your grant hopes and
dreams on and so I think that one of the
first duties of all politicians is to
announce the politics in the Sun our
life and Senator staffs is one of the
things we love so much about you so your
new book which I really want to get to
the vanishing American adults are coming
of age crisis and how to rebuild a
culture of self-reliance it's debuting
at number three on the New York Times
bestseller list for nonfiction and this
is actually a book folks I mean it's not
just a politician wrote a memoir and now
you should go buy it because politician
needs to make money and put its kid
through college although I assume that
Senator stats would like to put his kids
in college with money but I think that
the book itself is actually an important
look at why it is that our common
culture is eroding we talk a lot on the
show
senators ass about the the social the
social capital that used to undergird
American society and that's basically
what your book is about correct exactly
right yeah it's a hundred vis social
capital is the term we should have in
screaming lights in these conversations
because that's what's eroding and then
all the politics are dysfunctional
downstream from that poisoned river and
so I I think that this book is a hundred
percent not about politics it's 99
percent not about policy it's the tiny
point that it touches on policy is
recognizing that education needs to be
radically reformed and there's going to
be different kinds of job training in
the future when people are disrupted out
of work and jobs at 40 and 45 and 50 and
55 years old but the vast majority the
book is about exactly what
you flag which is social capital the
American experiment recognizes that in a
broken world you're going to have
structure you're going to have orders
you're going to have security there's
going to be restraint but what we want
the American founders wanted what I
think the vast majority the American
people actually want if you put the
choice to them is they want self-control
self-governance self-discipline
self-restraint
not power and discipline and restraint
coming from another from a political
center and right now this city DC is so
populated by folks whose only long-term
thought is about their own incumbency
that they come to think that politics
are the center of life anybody who
thinks that the politics of the center
of life is not well suited to be an
American politician so senator says I
want to ask you a question that I was
asked last night at Northwestern
speaking there about a lot of these same
exact issues and it's I think the
hardest question for politicians
particularly and that is it's easy to a
certain extent to say here's what we
need to do if we're starting from
scratch right you're you're 20 years old
you're not married yet
and now you're planning your life and I
assume that your book is making the case
that you need to get married you need to
bring your children up in a place where
there is social capital we need to make
connections with each other at the local
level at our churches and community
level and is his hook villian sense but
what we what do we do about the person
who's already made a decision that takes
them out of that so you have a single
mom she's already made the decision that
she a bad decision that she was can get
pregnant out of wedlock now she has the
baby and she maybe doesn't have that
that support network what do we do about
that you know I call on people to to
provide charity but for some people they
say that's not enough of an answer well
what do you think we ought to be doing
about that yeah it's a very fair
question so you know we live east of
Eden we live in a fallen world where
things are broken and we're all and in
my worldview were not only all sinners
were also all sinned against and so
everybody's always got grievances and
pain and some people have pain that's
much more substantial than others of us
have ever experienced and so the first
thing we need to do is have a shared
understanding of what we can and can't
accomplish in the world and what you
want is a world where people are finding
meaning in their local community where
they have meaningful work where they
have families where they have social
capital or they have friendship
they have intergenerational
relationships where they have the time
and space to wrestle through the really
big and important questions which are so
much bigger than politics and what we're
really describing there is neighborhood
what you want people to have is
neighborliness you want them to have
friendships you want to want them to
have meaningful work and so we need to
start by admitting that there is scar
tissue in the world but scar tissue is
often to be celebrated because scar
tissue is the foundation of future
character there is healing and there's
there's repair
there's rebuilding that happens among
neighbors and friends as they work
through those problems together
charles Murray sometimes uses the the
lime that government's job is to take
the difficulty out of things but you got
to be clear about what things you want
the government to take the difficulty
out of versus not I want the government
to take the difficulty out of walking
home from a restaurant late at night I
don't want there to be violence and in
anybody's neighborhood when they're
walking home from a restaurant or
walking home from work late at night but
I don't want the government to take the
difficulty out of cleaning up puke from
my six-year-old in the middle of night
because if the government tries to come
into my house and solve that problem
what it will actually do is create
passivity in me and it turns out as I
have three kids 15 13 6 I've had many
many sleepless nights over the course of
my life when my kids are sick in the
middle of the night and my wife and I
are on the edge of arguing with each
other about why the other one didn't do
enough to prevent this stupid thing from
happening you know why would you let
your kid eat that then Apple slice off
the floor of the athletic arena that's
the food poisoning that made him sick
but you know what happened when we
headed together clean up that puke in
the middle of the night we have a shared
experience it was the foundation of
future love future healthy nostalgia
future character and my kids they feel
that we care for them because we do but
we've demonstrated it at real moments in
time and so I think that your flagging
all of the brokenness of different
neighborhoods and different social
capital and different community
government we should talk about it
because there are things that government
should do to mitigate some of the
suffering but we first have to have a
shared understanding the government
can't possibly bring about youto
government won't be effective at helping
us clean up from a sick kid in the
middle of the night so we have to
understand that government is limited
and bounded don't let's have a
meaningful argument I'll say one more
thing here I think it's important to
distinguish between our commitments
you're in mine too limited government
and too small government because you and
I believe in both of them but limited
government is far more important than
small government limited government is
understanding that government is not
utopian and that rights precede
government government isn't the author
the source of our rights small versus
medium-sized government should be what
the debate is between the Republican the
Democratic Party
how much intervention should there be in
the economy and there could be Democrats
who if they would give a full-throated
defense of limited government and then
make their argument for medium-sized
government I might vote differently than
they would but we could stand together
at the kind of press conference you're
talking about and reaffirm basic
American values and virtues and then we
could argue about the stuff we vote on
but we'd recognize this stuff that we're
voting on is central it's not ultimate
theological philosophical dreaming
senator Ben Sasse the vanishing American
adult terrific book and Senator staffs
one of the few honest men left in
Washington DC really appreciated showing
that that you know a phrase that is
overused but under understood common
sense still exists thanks so much
senator SAS for joining ben shapiro show
really appreciate your time and
appreciate everything you're doing
thanks we have a great day already so
folks meanwhile I mentioned it to
senators ask they're the big story of
the day obviously is what's happening in
Montana's there's a special election in
Montana today the Democrat and the
Republican are running pretty close
together and it's now been thrown into
turmoil because look like the Republican
was going to win is a guy named Jian
Forte Greg Ginn Florida and Greg Jian
Forte last night apparently he was he
was being asked a question by Ben Jacobs
who's a reporter for I think Politico
but in any case he oh sorry for the
Guardian and Jim forte apparently grabs
this reporter and bodyslams him and this
guy tweets out last night that I was
bodyslam my glasses were broken here is
the reporter Ben Jacobs his description
of being attacked last night I just
wanted to take her she was standing
around there just to reach out and get
his response to see
Oh score on that he'd been talking about
that he'd been holding off his opinion
on health care at least under stunt
until he saw the CBO score next thing I
know I'm being body slammed and he you
know he's on top of me for a second my
glasses are broken the strangest the
strangest moment didn't my entire life
recording he perhaps my recorder and
iPhone it but the audio should be up
right now in the Guardian and yet throws
me down my glasses break II said if I
think I'm pretty sure he's on company
whaling for a second and I'm screams at
me to get the hell out and yeah his
staffer comes in it's just very strange
and mortifying because you know I'm used
to God you don't even know holiday
didn't until a lot of people on the
right immediately go well we hate the
media so he must be lying or we watch in
for day one him to win so this must all
be false okay as someone who has a
little bit of experience in these arenas
where people claim that an assault or a
battery is not an assault or a battery
because we don't like the person who's
being assaulted or batted around or we
don't or we do like the person who's
committing the assault and battery I
have a basic standard on this I treat
politicians like I treat every other
human being and that is to say when they
commit assault or battery that is
something wrong that is something bad
now the right immediate tendency which
was oh it couldn't have happened the way
this reporter said it happened that sort
of fell apart when number one audio came
out of the actual confrontation here's
what it sounded like there's no video
but here's audio of the actual
confrontation between this fellow Jian
Forte the Republican candidate in
Montana and this reporter Ben Jacobs and
we'll talk about that later
yeah but there's not gonna become a
discursive Eddie I think you Shane
please put you
tired you guys the last of the king who
you did the same thing
get the hell I choose get the hell out
the lines I do the same to you in the
garden yes if you just broke many
muscles you last got to be the same damn
thing you just body slide me at broke my
glasses get the hell out of here
yes I mean the audio is about as clear
as it can be and then fox news comes out
and confirms the accounts again very
reminiscent of past situations but the
Fox News reports that as part of our
preparation for a story about Thursday's
special election to air and special
report with prepare we arranged
interviews with the top two candidates
I joined field producer faith Mangan and
photographer Keith rally in Bozeman for
our scheduled to interview with June for
10 person writing as Alicia hakuna who
is a reporter for for Fox News and says
at this point she unfortunate grabbed
Jacobs by the neck with both hands and
slams him into the ground behind him
faith Keith and I watched and disbelief
as June 4k then began punching the
reporter as June 14 moved on top of
Jacobs he began yelling something to the
effect of I'm sick and tired of this
Jacob scrambled to his knees and said
something about his glasses being broken
he has faith Keith in myself for our
names in shock we did not answer
Jacobson said he wanted the police
called and when to leave chin for a
looked at the three of us and repeatedly
apologized at that point I told him in
Scanlan who is now president present
that we needed a moment and then the men
left so a few things to be said about
this I want to talk about the rights
response to this I think it's more
interesting than the left's response the
less response is at least largely
hypocritical so we'll say about that
briefly first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at my Patriot supply
so if you are looking at the world right
now and feeling uncertain about the way
that the world is working if you feel a
little bit scared about what's going on
North Korea if you feel like natural
disasters could happen and the
government wouldn't be able to take care
of you that's why you need a floor week
emergency food supply for just 99 bucks
again this is the stuff that you just
put in your closet you forget about it
until an emergency arises and then
you're glad these spend the $99 and you
get free shipping as well the order now
eight eight eight eight oh three
fourteen thirteen eight eight eight
eight oh three fourteen thirteen or
online and prepare with Ben comprehend
calm and you get that four week
emergency food supply for just $99 the
food
apparently tastes like home cooking for
people in studio tell me it's prepared
with been calm four-week emergency food
supply for just 99 bucks plus free
shipping and that makes sure that you
are covered in case of emergency okay so
the right response to this news vet
reinforced has online last night when
this happened and half the right says
this is pretty terrible and the other
half of the right goes well it can't
possibly happen that way but the people
who are really egregious say things like
well he had it coming
if you believe that a reporter can be
bodyslam because you don't like
reporters then let me let me say to you
that you are doing American wrong you're
doing you're just being an American
wrong Americanism does not constitute
people body-slamming reporters because
you don't like the question especially
when the question was can you give me
the ax natural question was can you give
me your opinion on the Congressional
Budget Office score of the new health
care plan that was actually the question
and he was body from one of the people
who I thought was just egregious last
night was Laura Ingraham she tweeted a
couple of times here was Laura Ingraham
sweet
she said politicians always need to keep
their cool but what would most Montana
men do if bodyslam for no reason by
another man we live in a civilized
society in a civilized society when
somebody assaults you the best answer if
you can do it is to withdraw and call
the police because a crime has been
committed the best answer is not to get
into tribal warfare where you then go
and clock the guy with a bottle and this
routine where it's like that the
reporter wasn't manly enough because the
reporter didn't stand up to being
assaulted is just ridiculous okay and
she she continued along these lines
sweet 14 she if we can grab that 14 yeah
she said did anyone get his lunch money
stolen today and then run to tell the
recess monitor okay if I had something
stolen from me I would run to tell the
police wouldn't you but again there's
this notion that there's this macho
brash stupidity that really is like high
school bullying that is emerged on the
right side of the aisle it's existed for
the parts of the left for a long time
but it's emerged on the right side of
the aisle where it's like civilization
takes you back to you I'd rather have a
macho guy there because strength
strength power power strength macho okay
you don't need your Congress people to
be macho you need them to be wise you
need them to exercise values you don't
need them to be body slamming reporters
so this sort of stuff is really gross
and I will say that it has risen in the
wake of Trump because Trump used to talk
like this on the campaign trail that is
true now the left is
on this to immediately suggest that it's
about Trump the June 14th admits and
he's going to get away with it because
of Trump I don't think that's right I
think that Trump is a symptom of
something deeper I think she in Forte's
symptom of something deeper Kirsten
powers who is a a person of the left she
says that it's really Trump's fault
because you need reporters all the time
it just happened it's mostly possibly
like tied into the fact that we have a
president that's constantly fomenting
rage against reporters I mean it's
possible there's some connection we have
a country doesn't trust reporting no no
but it's at a different level than it's
ever been I mean we it there's no
comparison to the way it is today than
even a year ago frankly the absolute
rage towards reporter okay this idea
that Trump's rage toward reporters that
people who don't like reporters of the
reason maybe it's the GM Forte's and nut
is the reason this happened you can't do
this what Kirsten powers is doing is
number 1 Trump isn't in Montana even and
number two the fact is that people on
the Left use this kind of language all
the time so for example last night K CNN
counterterrorism analyst was very angry
at Trey Gowdy's on the House
Intelligence Committee and this CNN
counterterrorism analysts said this
about trey Gowdy he field that's what's
so frustrating did collusion exist
that's the burning question that
everybody wants answered and then
Brennan says well I know of contacts and
communication well trey Gowdy ought to
have a kid he knows the difference
between intelligence and evidence let me
tell you something Allison if you're an
American citizen and the national
security agency collects intelligence
that is intercepts of Russians who
report what you've said do you think
it's fair to go to a court and say
that's evidence that you did something
wrong that's why the FBI is going to
take a year or more to investigate this
because the American citizens involved
in this have a right to have evidence
presented in a court beyond a
conversation that a Russian official
reports in my world this distinction is
black and white there's a hard line I
know it's frustrating for the American
people but I hope they don't want
evidence to be perceived as something
that a Russian official says and that's
it you can be convicted on that okay so
he actually goes ahead and he says
somebody should kick out his ass it's
really ridiculous that people on the
Left can say that and again they'll say
that this rhetoric causes no violence it
causes no violence when Barack Obama
says things like bring a knife to a
gunfight but
cause violence when Trump says things
like I'm going to defend somebody who
punches somebody all of these things are
wrong okay so now with that said I want
to show you why it is that people are
going to vote for this guy Gian Forte
anyway and there's a logic to this so
we're going to actually get out the
Glenn Beck charts we're going to get up
and going back a whiteboard and do a
full on chart here we go so I know that
game theory has become sort of a joke I
know that people think that game theory
because on Twitter somebody some guy
badly laid out game theory but there's a
real game theory reason as to why people
are going to end up voting for Gian
Forte so this is a basic prisoner's
dilemma in game theory game theory is
really about how to how two people play
a game together how they come up with a
strategy and the problem is that there's
no coordination at the top level between
the Republican and Democratic parties to
say that bad behavior means you won't be
seated bad behavior means that we're not
going to side with you are going to pull
support so what you actually have in the
right hand centers for a long time is
the left will endorse any bad behavior
so long as it serves their side we can't
be the only ones who are virtuous and
you can see how this leads everyone into
worse behavior at least two were
standards for everyone so the way the
game theory works is basically this is
the most basic form of game theory it's
the most famous form of game theory this
is called the prisoner's dilemma so here
you have prisoner one okay and here is
prisoner number two okay and the end
they are arrested for they're arrested
for murder okay they both killed
somebody together and now they're
arrested and so they do what they do in
LA Confidential they put them in
separate interrogation rooms and they
tell one of them here's the deal the
deal is this if you confess and your
partner does not confess then you get
off scot-free you can blame it on your
partner right you can just say my
partner did it wasn't me if both of you
confess you're both going to jail for
five years if neither of you confesses
if neither of you confesses then we
can't really convict you so we'll put
you in jail for like a year for some
lesser crime and if you're the person
who doesn't confess if you're the person
who stays silent and your other guy
blames you you're going to end up
spending 10 years in prison so that's
what it looks like on the board here so
on the board basically each of these
prisoners has two choices choice number
one is to stay silent choice number two
is to confess right choice number one
stay silent
number two to confess so there's a
prisoner one prisoner to the penalty as
I just laid it out is if somebody if
both of them are silent if both of them
are silent then they both go to jail for
one year right if prisoner one confesses
and prisoner two is silent then prisoner
one goes free because he blames the
other guy and prisoner two gets ten
years in prison if they both confess
they both get five years in prison and
if again prisoner one stays silent and
prisoner two confesses then prisoner two
ends up with then prisoner one ends up
with ten years in prison and prisoner
two ends up with zero years in prison
because the person who ended up
confessing is the person who ends up
going free basically so how does it
apply how does this make sense okay so
in the context of voting when people say
it's a binary choice when people say the
Democrats are going to cheat anyway so
it doesn't matter what you do they're
going to cheat the reason that both of
these prisoners are going to end up
confessing is because they don't trust
each other if they trusted each other
they would end up here right if they
trusted each other they would both shut
their yaps and they both spend a year in
prison and then they'd go free if they
don't trust each other if prisoner one
thinks that prisoner two is going to
confess then he has two choices right a
prisoner one thinks that prisoner two is
going to confess then he's either going
to spend 10 years in prison or five
years in prison so he is going to
confess also and a prisoner 2 thinks the
prisoner 1 is going to confess he has
the same exact choice he can either
spend 10 years in prison or I can spend
5 years in prison so if they don't trust
each other they're both going to confess
and so you actually end up is the
prisoner's dilemma and this is what that
I believe they would call the Nash
equilibrium in this particular scenario
this is where they would actually end up
they would end up in this box if you
don't trust each other you end up in
that box now the Republican Party and
Democratic Party don't trust each other
the Democrats think the Republicans are
going to always elect the worst guy no
matter what and the Republicans think
the Democrats are always going to elect
the worst guy no matter what so they
don't want to be in the position where
the Democrats cheat the Democrats put
Teddy Kennedy in office and they don't
care about it and it's fine it's all
good and then they're the ones who act
virtuously they say you know we're not
going to vote for our guy because it's a
bad guy and then we lose and Hillary
becomes president and we lose in this
Democrat Montana becomes president they
don't want to end up in this
so instead they say well vote for the
crafts guy the guy who's a piece of crap
who body-slammed reporter and you end up
in this box in other words the trust the
distrust that we have for Americans with
one another we end up both making the
second worst choice
right we both end up making the second
worst choice which for the country as a
whole is basically the worst choice
because now both of you are in the worst
situation the worst politician is always
elected right everyone elects the worst
politician because you don't want to be
a guy left out on the outside now this
assumes two things it assumes number one
that the person who is the the criminal
in this particular scenario is the best
candidate and doesn't do any damage down
the road I think that's a bad assumption
I think that if GN Forte is elected in
Montana that Democrats will use that as
a club to beat Republicans with four
years in the same way that they're now
going to use Trump to get Republicans
per year so there are costs down the
road and I think that's what senator
staffs was saying earlier senator sass
was basically laying out that short term
it looks like the best situation is this
but long term you're not going to really
win much more doing that and you're
going to undermine your own credibility
because you're a criminal so that's the
that sort lay at least hear the the
contention would be you maintained your
silence because you were innocent right
you didn't confess because you were
innocent so that's the right none of
these scenarios and the prisoner's
dilemma actually take into account what
if one of the people's innocent right
what if you're innocent maybe you go to
jail anyway but if you're innocent in
any way you can't actually confess so
that's the values argument is that we're
actually outside the scope of this
entire argument for values reasons we
can't confess we have to remain silent
regardless of what the other side does
but from a pure sort of political
political pragmatism point of view
you're going to end up in that bottom
circle so how do we cure that how do we
care that in order to cure that we
actually need a leadership of both
parties it can't be on the voters it has
to be on the leadership of both parties
because we can't it's going to be too
hard to get all voters all across the
country to say we're not going to let
people who body-slamming people that's
clearly the voters there's a huge
percentage of them who don't care they
don't care if a politician does
something bad so you really need is a
common deal between the leadership of
both parties I'm talking about Schumer
and McConnell and Paul Ryan and Nancy
Pelosi that they are not going to seat
people who are convicted or accused what
I would take convicted of crimes people
who are convicted of crimes will not be
seated in the Congress right we're just
not going to seat them and if
we think that the evidence is sufficient
that they will be convicted then we will
then we will not stand by them now the
leadership of a party is going to do
this because they don't want to lose the
seat because then they lose their
majority but that's what actually needs
to happen you actually need to get to
the point where instead of this we are
here in order to get from here to there
we actually need to have a deal between
both parties you need to show your
commitment and you can't pre-commit just
you the other person also has to commit
and you have to trust them so we have to
build a shared trust then we're not
going to see people who are absolute
pieces of crap okay so that's the basic
reason why people vote for the second
worst option and that's also the reason
why we do need a deal as Americans and
we need to build up the social capital
the Senators staff is talking about
otherwise we end up in that bottom right
square and that's the worst thing for
the country because now we're all
criminals and go to jail for a long time
that's basically the logic there okay so
with all of that said I want to I want
to move on on Daily wire calm and then I
want to talk about what the CBO is
reporting in other news so you're going
to go to daily wire calm in order to
subscribe to that $8 a month will get
you a subscription over at daily wire
and with that subscription you get to be
live on the you get to see the rest of
the show live you get to partake in the
mailbag which we are doing in short
order here on venture Bureau show which
will be lots of fun and you get to have
all your questions answered you get to
see Clavin show live get to be part of
his mailbag if you're if you've been to
an annual subscriber today we are giving
away a free signed copy of say it so
it's a book written by me and my dad say
it so Papa dad me and the 2005 Chicago
White Sox championship season really
good book endorsed by Mark Levin
endorsed by Dana Perino not even
available yet for general consumption
endorsed by a Jurek Resnick over at ESPN
Saru good sports book it's a really good
book about dads and sons there's a lot
of fun to write and my dad and I have a
really good relationship so obviously
it's it's I think a lot of fun to read
as well you get a free signed copy when
you become an annual subscriber or if
you just want to listen later then go
over to iTunes or SoundCloud we've a
rating leave review subscribe we always
appreciate it
we are the largest conservative podcast
in the nation
[Music]
Oh